Big voting 22 all one word, all lowercase,
big voting 22 and you'll get a beautiful discount.
Well, as I've been saying for about a month
and a half now, if there are going to be serious
criminal charges against the upper echelon
of the Trump Circle, I believe they are more
likely to come from the Georgia investigation.
Remember, that's the one where Trump wanted
votes.
I need 11,000 votes.
Give me a break.
That one, then from what's going on with the
January six committee, that's my opinion.
Now, it could be wrong.
And indeed, we are getting a sign that there
could be trouble in paradise.
Rudy Giuliani, Trump's former lawyer, Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham, as well as Trump's
former lawyer, John Eastman, have been subpoenaed
in the Georgia.
It's actually Fulton County grand jury probe.
Rolling Stone writes The Fulton County grand
jury's probe appears to be closing in on the
former president who pressured Georgia's top
election officials to find the votes.
I need 11,000 votes.
Give me a break.
Needed to overturn the election.
They have slapped a bevy of subpoenas on several
figures tied to Trump, including Rudy Giuliani,
Lindsey Graham, John Eastman, John Eastman's,
that very outrageous lawyer who wrote the
plan for how Pence could potentially overturn
the results and then was advised to get a
criminal lawyer by Eric Hirschberg, Cleta
mitchell, Kenneth Cesaro and Jenna Ellis,
all of which were involved in Trump's scheme
to overturn the election, also received subpoenas.
So too did Senator Lindsey Graham, the Atlanta
Journal-Constitution notes Giuliani testified
before Georgia lawmakers three times following
the 2020 election and that the ludicrous,
unfounded claims about election fraud during
that testimony has drawn the interest of the
grand jury.
Remember, Rudy was flying around the country
with flatulence and COVID.
I'm not.
It's just it's what it is.
I'm just telling you what it is doing.
Hearings where, if I recall
correctly, no one was under oath, like almost
ever or maybe ever.
And he was making a fool out of himself.
He was making a fool out of Trump.
It was crazy.
So Rudy is the target of a subpoena.
Lindsey Graham allegedly called Georgia Secretary
of State Brad Raffensperger to ask if he had
the power to toss out legally cast absentee
ballots.
So Lindsey is being sucked into it.
And John Eastman as well.
The subpoenas which were issued yesterday,
come as the grand jury has been hearing testimony
from a parade of witnesses.
So there's a couple different things going
on here that I think are important to consider.
First of all, when I look at Lindsey Graham,
Lindsey to me seems like the exact type of
guy who will throw anybody under the bus to
save himself.
Rudy seems like the type of guy who others
throw under the bus, and so far, that's the
way it's worked out.
Lindsey has flip flopped a dozen times now
on Is Trump good or bad?
What was the deal with the 2020 election?
You might remember very early on the morning
of January 7th, after midnight at roughly
maybe just before midnight, Lindsey gave the
speech on the floor of the House or Senate.
Don't remember where they were convened at
the time and said it's time for it to end.
The election is over.
And people looked and said, Oh, good, what
a mature guy.
But then he walks that back and he says the
irregularities, this, that, the other things.
So Lindsey is the prototypical guy of I'll
say whatever I need to say right now to save
my own ass.
Rudy has just been getting slapped around
by everybody.
Trump And they all it's.
And
so everybody is kind of playing their role.
The question about John Eastman is an interesting
one.
Eastman.
He wrote this seven point or however many
points there were a plan for how Pence could
send the election back to the States.
But he seemed to acknowledge, based on testimony
given to the January six committee, I think
that he sort of knew it was bogus.
And then he was advised to get a criminal
lawyer because what he was sort of suggesting
is arguably against the law very clearly seems
to be against the law.
So I don't know what the direction will be
there.
Now, there have been many people saying are
they going to fight these subpoenas?
Are they going to ignore these subpoenas?
Well, they'll do everything they can to delay
their appearances.
But contempt of court is different than contempt
of Congress not showing up.
When the January six committee wants you to
show up is one thing, and we've seen some
criminal referrals, but not showing up when
you're subpoenaed by a court is a different
thing.
So my expectation is they'll delay the appearances
as much as possible and then they'll show
up and assert their Fifth Amendment right
to avoid self-incrimination.
And I don't know that you're really going
to see them in serious legal trouble, but
we're going to follow it.
Now, the one other aspect of this is people
have been asking about extradition.
My understanding is that within the within
the U.S. states extradite.
Like if you know Rudy, I don't know where
Rudy lives now.
Maybe he's in New York, maybe he's in D.C.
I'm not sure if Georgia calls New York and
says, you got to extradite Rudy.
He's in contempt of court.
My understanding is New
York does it that New York will do it, but
we will allow other lawyers to weigh in on
that as well.